BUKOLA AYODELE:
Today, we're talking
about user-friendly SQL, Cloud
Scheduler, and cybersecurity
in health care.
I'm Bukola.
And welcome to
this week in cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
We're expanding BigQuery's
commitment to user-friendly SQL
through a whole slew
of new SQL features.
From expanded SQL expressions
and scripting control
statements to expanded data
types and information schema
views, we're making BigQuery
easier for you to use.
Check out the blog for more.
Reliably executing
tasks on schedule
is critical for
everything from data
engineering to infrastructure
management and application
maintenance.
Today, we are
thrilled to announce
that Google Cloud Scheduler,
our enterprise-grade scheduling
service, is now available
in more GCP regions.
In addition, multiple
regions can now
be used from a single project,
removing the prior limits
of a single region per project.
With all the crises that
have buffeted the health care
and life science industries
over the past few years,
one that often gets overlooked
is the unceasing wave
of cyber attacks aimed at
medical, research, educational,
and public health organizations.
The best way to put an end
to these persistent threats
to improve the resilience of
health care organizations'
IT systems, they
might do well to look
at their own industry
for inspiration
and an approach akin
to exposure therapy.
Check out the blog
for more details.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.